this is where it all began
the story of candy man local character
he walk around handing out candy to the
neighborhood kids
one day a couple of kids get razor
blades in their candy
police come around that's when i saw the
true face of fear
get on your knees hands hands
they beat him tortured him killed him
right there on the spot a couple weeks
later
more razor blades and more candy
he'd been innocent so he's real candy
man ain't a he
candy man's the whole damn hive
if you're out here looking for candy man
you ask me
stay away
i feel really connected to this story
god
right here in this neighborhood
the legend started uh-huh and the legend
is
if we say his name five times while
looking in the mirror
we could summon him summon the candy man
hell no
candy man anthony nose candy stop
i don't want to get creeped out in my
new apartment before bed okay
black people don't need to be summoning
no i dare you don't say that say he's
like
a candy man you better not do that last
one
you want to be a part of the story right
no
say his name candy man
[Music]
anthony anthony
anthony are you okay
the hell is going on this neighborhood
is
haunted i think i made a mistake
i brought him back candyman isn't real
he chose he has purpose for you
tell everyone
new to the neighborhood you should say
candyman say his name
you